tough times sometimes call for tough
measures since MGM announced that no
time to die was pushing us April 2020
release date back to November due to
concerns about the corona virus outbreak
film exhibitors everywhere we've grown
nervous about when and where the other
shoe will drop it's rather a lose-lose
situation as it stands right now no
matter what route is chosen as USC as a
patronage could possibly fall
precipitously by the time the next major
blockbuster release Black Widow is
slated to release in theaters the
current conversation regarding potential
release state delays has some
speculating that Disney and Marvel
Studios may push the film from a
scheduled May 1st debut according to
Deadline the outlet notes that quotes it
wouldn't be draw dropping if Disney
decides to move Black Widow but there
are some tricky logistics to discuss
sounds like a real party huh Asian
market box-office revenue it's important
to the franchise's success and the
coronavirus situation in China and Korea
in particular is especially concerning
for tournelles however moving the
release of Black Widow in hopes of
deferring interruption by the
coronavirus is an expensive and
potentially confusing effort for the
consumer base that may not be paying
attention to shifts in the film release
schedule and may not show up when the
new release date comes around but
coronavirus has a potential to be a
seasonal events like influenza even
though time will certainly provide more
treatment options our global efforts
work hard to find them one exhibitor was
quoted by deadline as saying we are in
uncharted territory so far tissie has
decided to stay as course for Black
Widows May first release date a Bond
movie changing release date is a big
deal
what would the guaranteed glitz and
glamor of a red carpet party attached to
every continental premiere but no time
to die isn't the marketing behemoth that
any Marvel Cinematic movie is yes black
widow was a surprise inclusion to the
expanding post Avengers endgame universe
given that the character died during
endgame after throwing herself off the
cliff in for Mia in order for a fellow
Avenger Hawkeye to obtain the sole stone
and until the events of Avengers
infinity war but no MCU film release is
just about the movie it's also about
expensive brand tie-ins like putting
black widow actress Scarlett Johansson
on soda cans and Dorito chip bags it's
about choice it also involves the rest
of Marvel's phase 4 movie schedule
inching along behind it
in other words Black Widow is more than
just a single movie right now it's the
first car of a whole train staring down
an economic hazard that had potential to
cause a major derailment in that sense
it might be safer to just release the
movie as planned and deal with screening
it and empty theatres for hoping to
recoup costs via other avenues later
another thing worth noting which might
indicate Black Widow sticking to its
planned release date is that DC and
Marvel Studios can take a financial hit
in a way MGM just can't no time to die
will probably be MGM's biggest
box-office draw of the year and the
possibility of releasing it in China
specifically when quarantines and
mandatory self-isolation orders are in
effect means guaranteed major financial
loss Disney faces similar difficulty
releasing internationally but it's also
a vastly larger corporation than MGM
with plenty of other major releases set
to come out over the rest of the year
including of course the other major MCU
release the Eternals in related recent
news Marvel Studios has halted
production on his Disney Plus series the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier due to
coronavirus concerns the show which
stars Anthony Mackie and Sebastian Stan
in the title roles was filming in Prague
at the time of the production's shutdown
according to Deadline the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier had moved production from
Atlanta to the European country for a
short shoot that began on Friday March
6th and was expected to be completed in
around one week on Wednesday March
eleventh Marvel executives sent everyone
else of Prague and back to Atlanta but
the chances of returning to Prague to
finish the shoot apparently seeming
unlikely the good news is that Disney
and Marvel have the freedom to put off
their and finish projects without too
much concern for major consequences in
the case of Black Widow it's
understandable that the studios would
want to stick to the plan all studios
are likely going to wince and
preemptively tighten the protected
earning belt buckle this year due to the
corona virus outbreak but at this point
in time there's no real reason to worry
about black widows fate whatever happens
we're sure we'll see it eventually
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos by
your favorite movies and TV shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one